en el vídeo previo trabajamos con este
conjunto de datos bip área 2 y
calculamos el coeficiente de correlación
y bueno este es un pequeño repaso y es
justo por eso que tengo la fórmula kim y
en este vídeo te decía que se pedía un
poco intimidante pero realmente lo único
que hicimos fue tomar un promedio del
producto de los puntajes zetas para cada
uno de estos pares y también dijimos que
si r era igual a 1 entonces tenemos una
correlación positiva perfecta y si r era
igual a menos 1 entonces teníamos una
correlación negativa perfecta y si r era
igual a 0 entonces no tenemos una
correlación ahora para este conjunto
particular de datos variados obtuvimos
una red de 0.900 46 lo que significa que
tenemos una correlación positiva
bastante fuerte y lo que vamos a hacer
en este vídeo es construir basándonos en
esa noción la ecuación de la recta de
los mínimos cuadrados que mejor trata de
ajustarse a estos puntos
antes de hacer eso intentemos visualizar
los conceptos estadísticos que tenemos
para estos datos claramente tenemos
gráfica 2 estos 4 puntos que representan
datos y vamos a empezar a trazar los
conceptos estadísticos para x así que la
media muestral y la desviación estándar
muestral para x las pondremos de color
rojo perfecto la media muestral para x
es muy fácil de calcular simplemente fue
uno más dos más dos más tres todo esto
entre 4 lo cual es 8 entre 4 lo cual me
dio 2 ok por acá tenemos la recta x
igualados muy bien y por acá tenemos una
desviación estándar muestral por encima
de la media y una desviación estándar
muestral por debajo de la media y
hagamos lo mismo con la media muestral y
la desviación estándar para y la media
muestral es 3 y por acá tengo la
desviación estándar muestral por encima
de la media y una desviación estándar
muestral por debajo de la media
y si visualizamos las medias podemos ver
que se intersectan en un punto y pasa lo
mismo con las desviaciones estándar lo
cual parece que nos da una idea de cómo
construir la recta de los mínimos
cuadrados así que de manera general la
ecuación de cualquier recta sabemos que
la podemos encontrar con la forma que
igual la mx más fe donde m es la
pendiente y ver la intersección con el
eje y ahora para la recta de regresión
voy a poner un pequeño sombrero aquí y
literalmente lo que esto nos está
diciendo este sombrero es que esta es la
recta de regresión que va a intentar
ajustarse lo mejor que se pueda estos
puntos ahora lo primero será pensar en
cuánto será esta pendiente
bueno la pendiente va a ser r por la
razón entre la desviación estándar
muestral para james sobre la desviación
estándar muestral para x y sé que tal
vez esto no suena nada intuitivo para ti
en un principio pero en unos segundos te
explicaré el porqué
ahora la siguiente cosa que necesitamos
saber es cómo podemos encontrar la
intersección y qué y bueno como
aprendimos en álgebra 1
nosotros podemos encontrar la
intersección bien si sabemos la
pendiente y uno de los puntos que pasan
por esa recta y para nuestra recta de
regresión de los mismos cuadrados
sabemos que en definitiva si hay un
punto que vive en ella es el punto la
media muestral de x coma la media
muestral de gem así que en definitiva
vamos a pasar por ese punto hasta ahí
muy bien y bueno ya sabemos por el vídeo
pasado que r es aproximadamente 0 punto
946 y que en definitiva nuestra recta de
regresión de los mínimos cuadrados va a
pasar por este punto ahora antes de
seguir con estos cálculos quiero ver qué
pasaría si r vale 1 es decir si
tuviéramos una correlación positiva
perfecta bueno entonces nuestra
pendiente simplemente sería la
desviación estándar para james sobre la
desviación estándar para x por lo tanto
si empezamos en este punto y caminamos a
la derecha una
un estándar para x y si hubiéramos una
desviación estándar para ella entonces
en una correlación positiva perfecta la
recta se verían simplemente así y es que
esto tiene todo el sentido del mundo
porque estamos buscando la dispersión de
quien entre la dispersión de x lo cual
sería nuestra pendiente en el caso de
que r valga 1 la desviación estándar
para ello entre las desviaciones
estándar para x es hacer en nuestra
pendiente y eso viene de una idea
paralela de lo que sabemos sobre rectas
recuerda buscábamos el cambio en tiempo
entre el campeón x es análogo a pensar
el cambio en la dispersión para james
entre el cambio en la dispersión para x
y bueno esto sólo en el caso en el que
erre valga 1 es más déjame escribirlo r
igual a 1 ahora qué pasaría si eres
igual a menos 1 bueno la recta se vería
más o menos así esta sería nuestra recta
si tuviéramos una correlación negativa
perfecta
y qué pasa si eres igual a cero bueno
nuestra pendiente sería cero por lo
tanto la recta sería simplemente y es
igual a la media muestra de la nieve lo
que me da esta recta de aquí pero ahora
pensemos en este escenario donde r es
cero punto 946 por lo que tenemos una
correlación positiva bastante fuerte y
muy cercana a uno bueno si tenemos a
0.900 46 y lo multiplicas por esta razón
entonces lo podemos ver la siguiente
manera si nos movemos a la derecha una
desviación estándar en x entonces que
tanto tendremos que subir en y bueno
pues nos vamos a mover r por la
desviación estándar de jim y como vimos
si eres igual a 1 entonces llegamos
hasta acá arriba porque tendríamos una
desviación estándar para el que completa
pero en este caso cuando r es igual a
cero punto 946 bueno observa tenemos
aproximadamente el 95% de la distancia
hasta arriba y por lo tanto nuestra
y eso que todavía no he dado la ecuación
de la recta pero ya puedo saber que
nuestra recta se tiene que ver más o
menos así que como puedes ver se ajusta
bien a estos puntos y lo importante es
que ya tenemos una intuición para esa
recta que espero veas que realmente no
sale de la nada
esta idea sale de un sentido intuitivo
como el que acabamos de hacer muy bien
ahora vamos a calcular la ecuación de la
recta entonces cuánto vale mi pendiente
bueno a mi pendiente es cero punto 946
que sabemos que es el valor de r por la
desviación estándar muestral en james
que sabemos que es 2.160 entre la
desviación estándar muestral en x que
sabemos que es 0 punto 816
ahora saquemos nuestra calculadora y
tengo cero puntos 946
2.160 entre 0.8 116 ok y obtenemos aquí
están 2.2 puntos 50 si redondeamos el
centésimo más cercano para simplificar
entonces m es aproximadamente 2.50 y
ahora como obtenemos la ecuación de la
recta bueno aquí vamos a recordar que
pasamos por este punto entonces tenemos
nuestra pendiente que es 2.50 por el
valor de x en ese punto que es el valor
en x de la media lo cual es 2
entonces 2.50 por 2 más ven y bueno esto
debe de ser igual a la media en james
que sabemos que es 3 entonces que
obtenemos bueno me va a quedar que 3 es
igual a 2.50 por 2 lo cual es 5 y
entonces simplemente obtenemos que 3 es
igual a 5 + b y por lo tanto ven es
igual a menos 2
estamos cinco de ambos lados y perfecto
aquí lo tienen la ecuación para la recta
de regresión y es el momento en donde
deberíamos de tener un redoble de tambor
para aumentar la emoción va a ser que es
sombrero igual recuerdan el sombrero lo
único que nos dicen es que esta es la
ecuación para la recta de regresión y el
sombrero es igual a la pendiente que es
2.50 por x menos 2
y hemos acabado así que nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo